[Musica]
sono roulotte e inventò col qualsiasi
cosa mi passa per la testa diventa
realtà
gli oggetti di tutti i giorni per creare
qualcosa di unico
gli studenti mi contattano perché hanno
bisogno di idee per risolvere i loro
problemi scolasti rulo abbiamo bisogno
di te vogliamo un mezzo di trasporto per
muoverci con comodità all'interno della
scuola ci serve una delle tue idee
geniali lui lo fa aiutaci tu
ho deciso di aiutarli per farlo mi
servirò di due super creator che
dovranno realizzare il mio progetto
questo e furia
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi sono fatti j
quando non mi alleno faccio lo youtube e
ogni tanto faccio pratica con ferite
ciao sono giulia penna e sono una
cantante con i capelli viola sono
bravissima nel fai da te non è vero
ragazzi benvenuti nell'area di fu fuori
al sud e carichi e arrivo nella più
fuori all'arena è stato veramente
fantastico di lorenzo giulia benvenuti
come ve la cavate con il fai da te
benissimo speriamo di riuscire a fare
una postazione decente
il mio rapporto con il bricolage
veramente drammatica
vi do la possibilità di scegliere due
aiutanti potete scegliere tra i ragazzi
4 al pubblico quindi giulia comincia
tutto lei
e lui ho scelto i miei aiutanti a naso
ha intuito a istinto non vorrei essere
da nessun'altra parte ma giulia piace
troppo
e poi
giulia giuliano ok perfetto
ci sono un sacco di ragazzi svegli
quindi in realtà è difficile trovare
qualcuno che non sappia fare il fai da
te siamo quinti nella squadra di parigi
le camicie i ragazzi spa b day
queste sono le vostre squadre adesso
consultato i dovete scegliere un nome
per il vostro team come la squadra
il nome della nostra squadra è team
viola è il mio colore preferito tutti
dicono che porta iella ma non è vero
allora dei condomini e dai sei lento
siccome dobbiamo trovare un nome che
vada bene ci chiamiamo i va bene
richiamati va bene sì ma che non mi va
bene adesso ragazzi è il momento della
ricreazione ma non quella che pensate
voi dovete ricreare quello che ho
pensato io io l'ho già costruito ed è
questo il tappeto volante che sapevo per
risolvere il problema dei ragazzi il
tappeto volante un tappeto volante
mi raccomando dovete farlo solido deve
andare veloce ma non dimenticatevi anche
l'estetica deve essere anche bello
impegnatevi perchè chi perderà sarà
sottoposto al test dell'assurdo teste
nell'assurdo cosa dovrete questo baule
qua dentro c'è il peggiore dei vostri
incubi che dire ti amo tantissimo il
test dell'astuto ok ragazzi prendete i
vostri telefoni e guardate il video
tutorial che vi ho mandato
fate molta attenzione questo è il video
tutorial del tappeto volante
cominciamo subito ha aspettato un attimo
ora ci serviranno due soffiatori
fascette di nylon nastro americano
argentato una tovaglia un telo in
plastica abbastanza resistente tubi di
questo tipo
queste sono imbragature d'arrampicata
però ancora non vi svelo a cosa
serviranno trapano e punta per legno con
le fascette di nylon assicuri
moschettoni cerco di capire dove fare il
foro quest'asse va messa qua e mezzo e
rinforza i bordi sempre con il nastro di
prima questi saranno gli scarichi
dell'aria che ci faranno volare
ovviamente non avrete capito nulla però
tolgo la parte originale e lo
sostituisco con quella flessibile
[Musica]
tutto chiaro ragazzi perché adesso tocca
proprio a voi
allora ragazzi vi piace il tappeto
volante meno sta roba è un genio quella
roba lì la voglio portare a casa è
meglio di no per moro velocizzato un po
il video tutorial perché altrimenti era
troppo facile tutto chiaro comunque non
ho capito una mazza ma preve non avevate
dubbi aiuto era ce la farò
sul tavolo poi dietro c'è tutto quello
che vi serve per costruire il tappeto
volante
avete fatto attenzione ci sono corde
soffiatori tappeti viti trapani di tutto
di più
non ho mai visto tutti quegli attrezzi
in vita mia avete solo 30 minuti di
tempo per correre partire da lì venire
sul tavolo prendere tutto quello che vi
serve è costruire il tappeto volante 30
minuti per costruire questa roba fosse
due vite non mi bastano però ci proviamo
dai tanto io vorrei avere un po di
vantaggio che quelle scarpe da
ginnastica
no perché lorenzo è più alto di me
voleva 2 bayern e la o magari parte
insieme a mai fare lo sgambetto se po fa
pure quello temo tantissimo fa vj credo
sia più bravo di me con la manualità che
poi tra l'altro voi non avete notato che
ci sono solo due soffiatori e invece ne
servono 4 2 a testa
come farete primo che rispondo ai suoi
fare allora entra l'onore di prendere
proprio i miei soffiatori no comunque
qualcosa ho capito poi dai siamo
intreccia in 31 capiranno
noi siamo uno per tutti tutti per uno ho
costruito personalmente un timer che
segnerà il 30 min in quelle un timer
certo se quello è un timer
io sono ruolo al miopia dovete scattare
e prendere tutto quello che vi serve
due piani
[Applauso]
[Musica]
la prima cosa che ho preso è stata
giulia mi ha buttato a terra poi si è
rubato tutte le cose che c'erano sul
tavolo e non ho ben capito questo ho
preso però col trapano qualcosa serve
entrambi i ganci guardo i ganci sono qua
giulia studia giulia i tappeti ha già il
tappeto no mi piace più quell'altro ma e
voi lo metti quella la donna a me non ho
capito ho scelto al tappeto lungo quello
da cucina perché voglio fare uno
strascico per farci sopra una passerella
bei ragazzi dovreste avere tutto
cominciate perché il tempo passa avete
poco tempo momento giulia aumenti
all'opera e mi manca stravano avg ha
preso tutte le cose che c'erano sul
tavolo ci sono troppi pochi oggetti
legali in due non bastano a vice non si
fa così
[Musica]
[Applauso]
brava giulia così mi piace allora un
soffiatore a destra e una sinistra ti
consiglio di fare i buchi molto esterni
prova meno male che hai un aiutante
sveglia lei naturalmente la scelta
perché si chiama giulia lo prendi un
pennarello scolo lancio viola cioè fai
la sagoma dei tubi abbiamo iniziato la
costruzione del tappeto ok allora prima
cosa facciamo asti cerchi per i tubi dei
soffiatori lorenzo tu fai attenzione il
resto dando dei consigli molto
importanti seguirli anche tu ragazzi è
semplicissimo basta prendere il kata
rifrattore ci potete per santander travo
anno devo fare buchi fuori da subito ma
tu sei monte fato buchi
ce l'abbiamo questa è la prima volta che
uso un trapano vi rendete conto a
julienne e si è pure bravate sonorità
soul trovano ragazzi son passati dieci
minuti movente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
abbiamo iniziato ma l'anello sembra così
facile montare questo modo è un fatto
per fortuna ruolo mi ha aiutato a fare i
buchi perché hanno paura di quel coso
aiuto trapano regalo per i bookie non
guarda ai fatti se si serve qualcosa poi
te lo daremo
avete come finto la vita fuori con cui
stai giocando lorenzo sotto
qualcun'altro trapano arancione cola e
brossel apre quello come trapano puntava
secontip e ci sto prendendo gusto ad
abitare tutte questi viti mi sento
davvero potente
non sei un gentiluomo rullo of dai dammi
la mano
il fatto è che io non pensavo che il
contraccolpo del trapano fosse così
potente fate qualcosa sulla tavola è la
squadra di fa dj io la vedo molto
confusionaria
non si preannuncia luca comi giorno
tutta la musica ragazzo è stato davvero
faticoso o alle braccia che mi fanno
male
vivete un po confusi lorenzo cosa c'è
che non va io posso vedere che hai fatto
4g
[Musica]
la porta lorenzo sul sole puntate le
aragoste
lì davanti ci sarebbero i buchi per
attaccare le corde e infarti più tardi
dovrete essere trainanti
allora il tappeto doveva essere ben
steso senza grinze perché se ci sono
greens e rob e poi si gonfia male e
perdiamo e noi non vogliamo perdere
[Musica]
ma questi fortunati parte
sono qui
ma direi
di vero
[Musica]
si dirà
e ora
[Applauso]
ora vieni con me
e verso un mondo di incanto dai intanto
io canto una bella canzone per il
pubblico così ma cappio qualche consenso
principessa è tanto che il tuo cuore
aspetta un sì quello che scoprirai è
davvero importante
il tappeto volante brava giulia sai che
sei una cantante lo sapevamo già però
qua devi costruire non è che dei
cantanti o ma i punti di squalifica
sono passati venti minuti e ne mancano
solo 10 dai dovevamo coprire tutte le
prese d'aria che ci potevano essere
perché quasi due a gonfiare dopo no alla
fine potete capovolgerla e ora da questo
lato buoni a tavoletta la rule of ha
detto che serve quindi la usiamo no
marullo non puoi andare sempre da giulia
stiamo montando i sofia cosi nella
quella tavola di legno e ce l'abbiamo
fatta
mancano cinque minuti dai mancano 5
minuti ma tanto noi ci siamo
incredibile quando mancavano cinque
minuti nelle verifiche ero messo sempre
malissimo
[Musica]
manca
10 9
5 4 3 2 1 fatta di ricordi
alfano in alto per mai da dove entra non
resta che il parere del giudice supremo
rullo
ragazzi complimenti innanzitutto perché
siete riusciti a costruirlo
cioè non ci speravo minimamente non
avevo nessuna fiducia il tuo lorenzo
sembra più io davo chiesto di fare un
tappeto volante sembra un tappetino del
cesso il mio tappeto viene dalla persia
direttamente cioè dal mio bagno che però
in persia allora vedo che hai messo
anche qua delle cose verdi scusa per
questa è la tua decorazione si prese mio
caro fa vj hai scelto male cosa affida
ok giulia tuo molto lungo poiché messo
un tappeto così lungo di me e che in
quella roba lì casa è il tappeto
passerella perché prima di risalire sul
tappeto farsi sul tattica tipo red
carpet tappeto di hollywood
ok ragazzi è arrivato il momento di
provarle andiamo allora si fa più seri
iniziamo con le gare andiamo andiamo
ragazzi questo è il momento di provare
quello che avete costruito questa è la
prima manche la prova di lancio dovete
farvi lanciare dai vostri compagni di
squadra e superare questa linea bianca
funzionerà tutto alla grande bisogna
crederci con la testa
quindi al mio tre accende i motori e
fatevi lancia 1 e 2 e 3
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ragazzi complimenti a entrambi i tappeti
hanno retto fino alla fine però giulia
hai vinto tu
i commenti ad ogni modo
ad ogni modo sappiate che qua non è
importante chi vince chi perde e si
vince o le e la prima manche l'abbiamo
vinta noi
vabbè lasciamo aperte poi arrivata alla
fine subito e non siamo partito questa è
una prova di tiro
dovete fare tre giri attorno alla
colonna attorno ai birilli
il primo che tornano a quella parte ha
vinto tutto chiaro quindi devo fare il
cavallo dei treni meno male che giuriati
a sap ormai 123
[Musica]
[Applauso]
seconda manche ha vinto tra vj
complimenti lorenzo la seconda l'ho
vinta io
perché perché ha barato perché mi ha
spento il motore e mi ha buttato a terra
adesso non abbiamo paura della targa
mani ragazzi questa è la terza manche la
prova canestro dove tema in termini
equilibrio si questi tappeti volanti e i
vostri compagni di squadra vi passeranno
le palle il primo che riusciva a fare
tre canestri avrà vinto 12
[Musica]
[Applauso]
a oggi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
lorella tua giulia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho vinto la terza sfida raga incredibile
confine nel caos a m
vi ricordo comunque che è importante chi
vince chi perde a decretare il perdente
sarà il caos ometro e quindi non accolte
al fuoco e adesso andiamo a casa
e questo è il caos ometro ed è un
microfono potentissimo ma anche
precisissimo con il quale sono in grado
di misurare il caos dei ragazzi ma siamo
sicuri che precisissimi di no vuoi
provarlo si vuoi cantarmi qualcosa non
ho ancora capito perché cammini e sempre
dietro di me
e ti assicuro lorenzi tutti i figli vuoi
cantare anche tu hai mi fido ok quindi
al mio tre iniziò a fare un gran caos
prima per giulia e poi passiamo a
lorenzo io non posso fare il test ed
assurdo non voglio farlo e non lo farò
io non lo voglio fare
non voglio fare uno due tre cartellini
[Applauso]
giulia complimenti più s'è aggiudicata
un 91.4 a leh dove casinò voglio
sentirmi questo timpa non deve fare
al mio tre fate caos per lorenzo 23
campo l'orecchio
[Applauso]
intanto lorenzo ti sei aggiudicato un
105.8 lorenzo vince e cosa ancora più
totale giulia ha il terzo ragazzi grazie
mille
[Applauso]
non è tutto ringrazio mia mamma e tutti
quelli che mi hanno insegnato il fai da
te dove serve intera pani potete farlo
anche tu genio quindi lorenzo vince ma
cosa ancora più importante per giulia
tu hai perso e con immenso piacere
avviati proprio immenso piacere
ti faccio vedere di cosa si tratta il
testo dell'assurdo quindi avvicina anche
al baule andiamo ad aprire sto baule
fare infirmorum
allora questo è uno spaghetti assistant
questi tool oppure bucatini assisterebbe
nvidia nozze subito la porchetta e anche
questo sarebbero mangiare questo è un
raffredda pietanze ma che è sta roba
fare una parabola e questi due oggetti
di curiosare ovunque in giro per la
città magari al ristorante in pizzeria
ovunque ve di juliaca fuori a ricantare
perdi o cantare vai a mangiare che test
dell'assurdo la vj nella pagherai quindi
buon test dell'assurdo quella è la
strada è un po di divertimento
sono i due oggetti che hanno cambiato
per sempre il modo di mangiare da oggi
gira gli spaghetti in tutta comodità o
raffreddare il cibo bollente ha tutto un
altro sapore
e arrivato il momento di provare gli
oggetti più cool del momento
ci devo prendere la mano costo trapano
perfetto grazie all amia grazie ciao
ragazzi avete pranzato si no io ancora
non ho pranzato con questo ci mangia
spaghetti e con questo invece c'era
predomina tra san ci vediamo
grazie ciao sì tutta colpa di roulotte
vabbè ok
profuma con mese fa che ok
bisogna usare quei giorni se con
delicatezza
diciamo che così è molto più facile
mangiare vi sembra di spaventi mi
spaventa un po mano
a posto vedi facciate mangiate
continuare
forse pensa troppo coperta
[Musica]
o
mannaggia a me che casinara che so io
cosa fai da te proprio è solo una che mi
fai fare questi quest'anno prende ben
macchina signori io vado a pranzo
spaghetti assistance e raffredda
minestre buon caffè apparirci
non ho questo non mi serve cioè il mio
non mi serve il cucchiaio un cucchiaio
passion per una minestra fashion
sciarpa lato delicato sì sì se compagna
anche tua azienda
funziona
numero buona a render posto più
piacevole
ma poi piacciono più spaghetti o la
minestra ma allora per spaghetti c'è
un'altra soluzione sempre the role of
questa cosa qua ti aiuta mangia più
velocemente e così a roma doni e metti
in bocca è geniale o roulotte spaghetti
mangiati e minestra pure direi che il
test dell'assurdo è stato proprio
superato grazie
[Musica]